you may not believe this but there are
quite a few Disney Princesses who were
set to star in their own movies but
never got the chance to these princesses
are amazing yet somehow they just didn't
make the cut
watch until the end to find out which
Disney Princess would have starred in
princess Academy but managed to get
shelved instead I'm a princess -
Clarisse Bala's little sister
it's a little-known fact that princess
Belle was originally going to have a
cute little sister her name was Clarisse
and she would have been a great
companion for Belle but they decided not
to put her in the story because they
wanted to emphasize Belle's loneliness
but it is fun to imagine what Clarice's
story would have been like maybe she
would have been a spunky kid who used
her cleverness and tenacity to rescue
Belle from the beasts captivity she
doesn't eat with me then doll would have
formed a relationship with beast without
you know being his prisoner and all I
ADA usually Disney creates an animated
film and then it goes on to be a total
hit I can't but in the case of Aida
Disney skipped the movie and took this
princess right to the stage in fact this
Broadway hit was originally going to be
an animated film first Audra McDonald
was all set to voice princess Aida the
studio even reported working toward a
live-action version of the movie which
would have starred Beyonce but neither
film went anywhere Aida is the story of
an enslaved nubian princess who falls in
love with an Egyptian captain it would
have been amazing to see Beyonce play
this Disney Princess but unfortunately
the movies were never made
this next princess is more like a
goddess than a princess eebee after the
success story of Disney's Hercules the
studio was all set to make a sequel I
wish to stay on earth with her Hercules
too would have followed Hercules his
wife Megara and their daughter Phoebe
for some reason the executives at Disney
decided not to move into production with
the film which was a major bummer
this little Greek princess would have a
powerful combo of Hercules a strength
and mogera sass maybe she would have
found out that she has goddess blood in
her veins even though her dad decided to
live among the humans her granddaddy is
Zeus after all we wonder what God is
like abilities this toga wearing
princess would have
still they probably would have paled in
comparison to this next Disney princess
Odette the story of a debt from Swan
Lake features all the major
characteristics of a Disney Princess in
this story the princess suffers the
tragedy of being turned into a swan who
can only assume her human form after the
Sun Goes Down the only way to break the
curse is to get her prince to fall in
love with her hmm that sounds familiar
doesn't it
Disney tried to turn this into an
animated film in 1992 but they lost the
deal the film was eventually released by
New Line Cinema still Odette would have
made an enchanting Disney Princess
this next princess is one you don't want
to miss Moorea mistress Michaan's repose
Maria is a lonely orphan who almost rose
to Disney stardom in the 80s she comes
from the 1946 novel mistress Michaan's
repose she lived a difficult life raised
by her cruel caretakers miss Brown and
mr. hater but then she discovers these
tiny people called Lilliputians who are
known from the tale Gulliver's Travels
together with her new little friends she
embarks on a bunch of magical adventures
this is ride out Disney's Alley
unfortunately the chairman at the time
disliked the story the film was already
in production when the movie was shelved
but who knows maybe they will take it
down from the dusty shelf one day
Penelope in the 12 months disney loved
the poem of young penelope it began as a
poem in the 1940s about a girl who used
a magical grandfather clock to travel
through time wait what during the course
of her travels she met otherworldly
beings which represented the months of
the year
Disney even went to spar to hire artists
Mary Blair to do some preliminary
sketches for an animated movie in the
movie Penelope looked just like the
princess she worked for and instead of a
grandfather clock she had a magical ring
Penelope used her magical ring to bring
flowers to the princess and the pair
became good friends sadly this movie
never came to pass
Minnehaha as part of Disney's musical
production titled Silly Symphonies an
animated short was made little Hiawatha
was a young Native American boy from a
Henry Wadsworth Longfellow poem
he had many adventures with the animals
through the forests near his village
Disney wanted to make a sequel to this
short about a Native American girl named
Minnie ha ha but they decided to put the
short story away in favor of making
Pocahontas instead my name is Pocahontas
it's unclear why they thought they
couldn't have two stories about Native
American girls maybe they will bring
Minnehaha back one day ROS McGee Barry
Cooke the co-director of Mulan was all
set to make a Disney film about a sort
of Appalachian Juliet called my people's
Barry was heartbroken that the movie was
never made saying that he poured his
soul into its story he said he opened
himself to all the things he loves they
casted the film included an animated
doll version of Abraham Lincoln he was
trying to help the star-crossed lovers
get together who wouldn't want to see
that
however Disney went with Chicken Little
instead this next princess would have
required going back in time the first
Queen before the tale of Snow White ever
became a Disney animated classic
it was a golden book in this picture
book from 1952 featured Snow White's
mother she was seen by a window and
sewing during a cold winter day suddenly
she pricks her finger at that moment she
wishes for a daughter with lips as red
as blood skin as white as snow and her
hair as black as ebony that's really all
we know about this mysterious character
but Disney missed an opportunity to tell
the story of Snow White's mother as a
princess seriously did she have magical
wishing powers or something an even
bigger mystery is the final princess on
our list princess Academy did you know
that Disney had plans to create a sort
of magical princess Fantasia they wanted
to put all their lead female characters
together in a movie including Sally from
The Nightmare Before Christmas and
characters from Who Framed Roger Rabbit
they were all going to interact with
each other at some kind of boarding
school there's even a movie poster for
this abandoned film project in the
poster there is one character we don't
recognize it's the fair maiden behind
Alice she looks like a centaur
perhaps from Fantasia that's a
pretty unusual Disney Princess we'd love
to know her story so which one of these
forgotten princesses was your favorite
let us know in the comment section below
if you love Disney Princesses as much as
we do be sure to subscribe to the things
to catch our latest princess videos and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up while you're at it
thanks for watching bye
[Music]